sensible et discret il n'aimait pas le
bruit et la fureur du
[Musique]
monde il aimait
profondément ses
filles sa mère et sa
sœur nous nous
[Musique]
aimions
Dominique ta
silhouette je la vois sur le perron du
lycée Gambetta quand nous arrivions
ensemble pour aller enseigner et que
nous gravissions ces quelques marches
alourdes par nos sacs nos copies nos
livres et nos idées alourdi mais
tellement léger parce que toi et moi
allions faire ce que nous aimions ce
pourquoi nous étions taillés
élevé ta silhouette je la vois dans la
salle des profs je vois ta chemise
toujours le gobelet que tu tiens ton
sourire malicieux parce que tu as un
truc marrant à
dire il était difficile de ne pas
s'approcher de ne pas t'écouter de ne
pas se laisser ravir par un conseil de
lecture une
anecdote un rien un tout ta silhouette
je la vois dans les couloirs devant une
classe un peu dispersée que ta présence
ramenait au calme parce que c'est
Monsieur Bernard alors bonjour
monsieur c'était aussi ça ton pouvoir
avec les élèves tu étais là pour eux il
l'avaient compris et se nourrissait en
désordre de ta passion dévorante pour la
littérature de ta foi en l'homme des
espoirs que tu met mettait en eux quelle
ironie
tragique que ce soit sur ce même Peron
où tu as usé tant de semelles que la vie
t'a été
ravie tu ne l'as pas cherché toi ce
clou il s'est planté en toi au hasard
d'une haine aveugle et
primitive quelle ironie aussi qu'un
geste aussi sombre aussi obscur et
frappé celui que Victor HUG aurait pu
appeler un porteur de
flambeau te voilà élevé au rang des
martyres toi l'homme
discret une passion en remplace une
autre et quelle perte pour le
monde je n'oublierai jamais ta
silhouette sur le Peron du lycée
Gambetta